I'm absolutely delighted that we could
find some time in the schedule of mr.
Vishnoi
who is extremely active in Silicon
Valley has been named by the San Jose
Mercury News as one of the ten most
influential people in Silicon Valley and
to get into mission into vicious
schedule today to talk a little bit
about what's going on in in South Asia
we'll start off let me give you a little
bit more of an introduction
vish has been a venture capitalist at
Clearstone Venture Partners since 2002
he serves as venture director there and
before that he had over 30 years of
leadership and management experience in
high-tech industries software internet
networking and telecommunications he was
a co-founder of exelon he was a founder
at talero corporation he was a vice
president at Novell software he's been
an executive vice president at I planet
and chief executive officer of for
start-up companies he has served on the
boards of over eight publicly listed
companies and especially connected to
today is a trustee of the large
organization the Indus entrepreneurs and
the last time I saw this was Friday when
dish was introducing the keynote speaker
for the tie con conference so ty Kahn is
the largest entrepreneurship conference
in the world very probably even you
think about TEDx you think about slush
you think about SXSW there were more
than 4,700 people at the Santa Clara
Convention Center on Friday and my
understanding is over a hundred and
sixty thousand people were live by Skype
and other kinds of video conferencing
technique
these people came from 22 different
countries there were 20 different tracts
and programs over 200 speakers and this
is presented by Thai which is a huge
organisation that is devoted to
promoting entrepreneurship it started
with some successful people from India
here in the valley
25 years ago and a lot of these
successful people are now charter
members of Thai and that involves not
only significant financial contribution
that involves a lot of contribution of
time to mentoring younger entrepreneurs
it's an absolutely incredible experience
um he wasn't on the program but roll
Khanna the congressman came by and gave
greetings that morning and Tim Draper
was the main keynote here as a company
from Scooba Japan who is exhibiting in
Tai Khan and Santa Clara last week oh
this was a senior vice-president Paul
West as his name of visa talking about
the technology should never get in the
way of the picture don't you like the
picture behind him so this was a session
out of the FinTech this is one of the
breakout sessions where there were only
about 200 people so this is shows you
that it's a very interesting and diverse
kind of group of speakers this is who
they were
I'm impressed to find out that Singapore
actually has a director of FinTech and
you know vice-president of lift on the
same panel and um you know co-founders
entreprenuer on the left-hand side allah
closely moderator of this session it was
nicely diverse although one of the
points that was first made in Thai at
the very opening of the plenary session
was that they want to really become the
inclusive entrepreneurs not just the
Indus entrepreneurs
and really try to get more women
involved we'll come back to that point a
little bit later in the session today
but first wish you must have had a nice
weekend after ty finished up get some
rest
just a little bit yes I did sleep for
six hours on Sunday and it slept
somewhere else yesterday so how do you
look at the conference this year was a
pretty much as usual any kind of
surprises or things you noticed oh yes I
think this really was by far the biggest
and the best conference actually the
number of registered attendees were more
than 6,800 actually Wow so we broke all
them all all of the rules of records
ourselves and you just alluded to some
of the speakers so besides the keynote
like Tim Draper and beyond coastline and
we had who got the Lifetime Achievement
Award from us the next morning we had
this old gentleman dr. Patrick son Shawn
he is the amazing innovator in cancer
stuff and so that was very good and all
the breakout sessions that we have 15
tracks you just talked about FinTech we
highlighted so we had tracks on
autonomous vehicles
you're a RV our drones gaming March hack
so all the newer technologies we're new
you know companies are getting formed so
they're over there their billions would
also represented by venture capitalists
and you know again you know visitors
yeah welcomed by afterwards and other
people in two rooms upstairs they were
there were basically continual pitches
by startup companies that were going on
at our to people who are real investors
who were talking about investing it
correct yes so we had two cancer patient
one well this was what we called the ty
50 Awards so we we stood that awards
program in 2009 when I was president and
that has continued so we go comb the
globe and we invite all the people to
apply and we go
very rigorous process of selecting so we
invite hundred and we picked 50 of that
so 100 are fully vetted so that the top
100 and so you saw the picture that
really are just a lot of young people
they want you in the world and you know
this is what we started you know so this
was 20 appear also so they were pre pre
amazing that we will do Salvatore 25
years of success they the other thing to
remember is that this is a
not-for-profit organization and it's all
volunteer let it produce a dad
conference II don't like volunteers Wow
and no one gets paid we don't have even
bangin people we just you know people
who are engineers it won't be market
here you know people who are marketed on
be salespeople and so it is a lot of
work and you know you're sitting side by
side rubbing shoulder with the
billionaire and you are aspiring eating
your lunch and work a signed everybody
so humble and good so these are the
charity works okay highly successful
people we Dwight in the joint and the we
only showed up with generals and Genesis
applying with you eight point out not
not with their money so tires a huge
organization how does it stay
entrepreneurial well well because our
mission has been the same since day one
we wanted to be a whole your admission
into foster entrepreneurship and to
encourage and promote hamper ship
whatever is welcome so we really care
every just something worse that's the
only single mission we have and we
believe that wealth creation to on
premiership is a noble endeavor and
that's how you build community that's
how you get back that's how I get
forward and we have not deviate from the
mission and that release champa and of
course you know now look at you know you
know in you know SEP 25 years the reason
weren't the works why because when we
have more younger people belong to the
group we actually honor this one
gentleman Jodie Bhansali was a young guy
nine years ago this fellow could not
even stay in this country because he
didn't know they could get visa but you
gotta be they start a company called
life dynamics and two months ago so -
Cisco 40 points seven billion dollars he
became a semi billionaire so we start we
give him unfamiliar world example
same thing with this other our own
member Robbie Maddison
we gave him venture capital D award
because he founded AB dynamic new tonics
and you know just the long list of
successful company
so we reckon anybody knows cause I
achieved a Lifetime Achievement Award
from us well he declared that he not
ready to retire yet but we felt that he
had a very good life yes yes so I think
that you know most organizations would
go absolutely crazy trying to put on one
event the scale but tires always got
things happening on a monthly basis I
remember seeing a set of Portuguese
companies come in pitch at the tie off
is down in Santa Clara yes and so could
you tell a little bit more about Thai
and what it is and what it does yeah so
I simply stated the mission value to
foster entrepreneurship and the genesis
of it basically was a lot of us who came
from you know primary of any Indian
subcontinent in the 60s and 70s all we
had was good health good education and
we came to America you know we took jobs
in companies or some of his you know and
I mean some people became you know like
a professor's academia and some people
who can successful entrepreneurs so 25
years ago we said gee won't that be nice
if we form a society and help anyone who
want to succeeded and who knows we could
we realized our American dream we said
let's share this thing so that's how the
genesis tie came about and and again the
mission is very noble you know creating
wealth through an Premiership is a noble
endeavor and that's how I build
community so we started in Silicon
Valley that's why it's rooted but then
you know later on you know other regions
in the u.s. primarily like Boston LA
Seattle they all started coming to us
it's a you know we want to start a
chapter and what has happened since then
now we're into 19 countries 61 cities
around the globe but the US India
quarter is still very strong quarter for
us where two dozen chapters in North
America we like doesn't have chapters
like CW
year three in Pakistan we have a one in
Singapore when in Malaysia
2 in Australia Tokyo then on the
Atlantic side we get Dubai you get
London Manchester
you know Germany Google Belgium
you know it's like that yeah and it is a
pull organization so we don't push we
don't say well we just want to go and
create a chapter there because people
have to be locally very successful they
want to build local communities to amp
ownership so they just come to us and we
you know help them and now so every
chapter you know so what we do we
basically you know we have a lot of
programs all programs are geared toward
and premiership and so we do two things
one is that okay every program had to
have inspirational aspect informational
aspect education dissect and you know
preparing animals aspect and also
funding a process right so that those
are kind of constants they don't change
over time but the other thing what we do
they will point them where the future is
so for example so that's what we
showcase so opportunity talent in the
less famous sort of any technology so
like we talk about our vehicles yeah we
are
drones FinTech mark tech boots and
opportunities we also have other
component we built three Albert Gulf
tables very important issue because a
lot of governments came to because
government you know every country
starting or Estonia for example of
Singapore though the two gummies
absolutely that's they're going so
digital is just unreal so we said let's
feature them and we invited other
governmental to come and talk about
innovation happening in government how
can you begin to provide their services
to your citizens and how can you also be
relevant to the citizens so that was
very very good youth we're getting we
introduced like in 2009 is we start
encouraging youth high school and you
know college freshman and senior and
sophomores come and consider and funchal
a noble career so that track where they
were attended the other thing about
called social impact so besides just
organizing for-profit ventures we also
encourage people to create nonprofit
ventures fairly the you know bottom
you know help me helping of the pool but
doing a business way don't is not a
charity not a handout but you should
really create opportunity that cater
should be kind of people and so every
chapter takes one or the other element
of Italy prototypes of the value website
for example we have already planned out
throughout the 1918 the calendar filled
out so we have forums who get
roundtables and they get summit and
around all these kind of topics and we
are constantly you know bringing people
who can share their story successfully
because you know it's that the
inspirational aspect you'll have enough
successful people we ask them to come in
just tell your story yeah that really
was very good yeah I've been really
impressed with the kind of global
expansion of Thai because especially one
of the things that we've seen in
previous sessions this series is that
mentoring is not well developed in a lot
of Asian countries yes and Thai has put
a lot of effort implementing not only
using what I would say not just the
Silicon Valley model but really doing a
lot that's kind of localized in the
different places where Thai has chapters
I helped out a few years ago with this
remote mentoring dynamo and I think that
on how Thai
approaches mentoring could you comment
on that a little bit yeah again you know
our mentoring is based in with England
and you know but you can go to a Thai
website and you can just you know just
request that I I need some advice we
don't judge you
we don't ask you what question you have
but advice is it's a good advice in a
sense that a lot of people they think
they want we are perverse and sometimes
after just having dug into us they
conclude that they're not it to be
enforced she's okay that's good because
you don't delete them down the wrong
path and then on the other hand people
really say I want ground floor and we
take a look at that so how strong is
your business plan how strongly the idea
what do we really have very chance of
succeeding
if not then these are the kind things
you should do and we do that it curly
just you know with nothing expected
return other working at work which has
happened over times like the way
were flying cement or and starts to work
closely with the mentor that we just
abandoned because if you really spend
taking a lot of time away from somebody
then you have to figure out a way if
you're going to start an adventure maybe
perhaps make this person a formula
advisor yeah and as a result that person
should have some kind of also incentive
like not a lot of options and stuff like
that not substantial so that you know
you feel and and that's all you might
have from work speaker it's now again a
charity don't go and seek charity if you
really want to you know create economic
wealth for yourself you should be
prepared to share them with others and
that will be very important okay a lot
of important they don't they don't
understand it
so you have to get other people involved
you know and as a result of this to this
mentioning or just accessing Thai people
have found their co-founders people have
found their investor people have found
their mentors field found their advisers
and that people just were white and this
world was an appetite well you know what
is that for this one particular event or
it was it not where I sat and had dinner
with somebody had a coffee somebody and
then you know I develop a long-term
friendship actually with people now they
tell us people live in has come to
Thailand they met other people that they
had this orbit before they get married
so that also happened yeah it it does so
it really I really encourage all of you
to rejoin Thai and I think you'll be
really you'll be impressed
yeah so thanks so let's talk a little
bit about what's going on in the
subcontinent
I've got a few slides on geo data point
that we can take a look at and talk a
little bit first about first of all
investment in India has really jumped up
in the last couple of years
this is quarterly each bar chart is a
quarter yes and so you see that it went
up to about four billion dollars total
in 2016 and for the longest kind of time
that was not quite a billion dollars a
year so it's really just in really since
2014 that the major jump up his hand
there are a lot of companies formed
every year in Thailand these are
specifically tech enabled companies not
just you know new shop stands fruit
stands or things I think these are
interesting numbers 52,000 in the US the
number I'm familiar with every year in
Silicon Valley is somewhere between
14,000 and 20,000 it varies depending on
the year so I'm that looks a little low
so if that's a little low maybe the rest
are a little low too but in any case the
government in India reported last year
that there were 19 thousand active
techid able to startup companies however
they define that and you know by the end
of 2015 there were already eight
unicorns and from in India but there are
some challenges India has a complex
regulatory framework and there is a
certain amount of what you don't call
corruption you call facilitation
payments for like the local police or
whoever right and the biggest problem I
think is that it's really difficult to
enforce a contract or sue somebody
because there's about a 10-year waiting
period for lawsuits to get the court
something like 50 million lawsuits
waiting to come to trial and it is still
the case that in India only about 10% of
the startup founders are women so it
does need to be more inclusive although
five years ago that was 6% so it's
moving in the right direction and maybe
the other thing is that IPO exits are
still kind of difficult if the company
doesn't come here to the US and go IPO
here the process is pretty difficult in
India and it's hard to raise really
sufficient amount of money to make the
process worthwhile so that's kind of the
whole thing how does this fit with your
perceptions what do you see happening
over the last few years
so really picking off yeah I think
definitely are picking up as you pointed
out you know the know jump in you know
the the investment activities that's it
is real that's happening and it just at
that point I'll just you know point out
together a lot of statuses are starting
out in India and India still needs more
venture capital then Italy has
especially at the early level or over
the early stage
I'll just contrast you like with China
for example seventy percent of the
Chinese solids in China they get two
hundred by Chinese money in India is
like 105 percent so it's please pretty
tiny some so more to the dollars that's
moving into India is a venture capital
it is visiting from us my firm clear
stone you know about now twelve years
ago we decided to go to India Africa two
of our partners have interview from
India and a lot of people going to China
so commodities your slot in rural China
so we said well let's just for the
individual we saw that India you know
you know has Lawrence Island and the
Indian entrepreneurs are a lot more
aligned with a u.s. Emperor's and they
relates a lot more to the American
culture and system for example so we we
talked about and we took our partners
and actually when I took our partners I
told them listen you have to come to
India because you really have to
experience because like what you see is
what you get and you land in India and I
want them that India also Anika you get
assaulted all your senses get assaulted
sitting so what I decide sound smell you
know everything gets assaulted same time
right so you get these satellites about
24 to 48 hours after you survive then
you begin to like India and no truth or
we're going like for 10 days and we win
to force it is so willing to Delhi
Bangalore Bombay which in Mumbai now and
putting those we figure for good hubs
and because we have tied chapter so I
had warned the people in advance as I
want you to get you
you would I mean by jumpin or just you
know just stuff to come over here and we
weren't listening to the story so we
sought 50 on summers and it's very
interesting you know most of the
Emperor's their pictures who are you
know kind of weak are not very ambitious
they all want to relay small money like
hundred thousand maybe two and thousand
and they want to build a business will
be two or three or four million dollars
this was the scene like 12 years ago a
lot of runners none of the people are
really fundable because we could have it
but that's how you go and you tell
people there were not from the war
culture in a small scale too small yeah
and you know for the early stage
investor you know for you know your time
you scan because they just wanted
ambitious enough but I think what
happened that's okay you know what we
said despite we we went and we committed
40 min loss which they will invest $14
and we'll treat them just like they're
over here so same standard because I
just like or listed you know investment
you didn't do a lot of hands-on support
okay not least indica where you're just
going to hand off and you just wait for
management in order to come so that work
I knew a lot of our colleague they also
went around same time work there and
they also put money into early state but
then they got impatient with the
donor-egg this so they are putting money
in the late state companies and they
will fund anything even they wanted to
take investable is on any company and
you know a lot of the song is what which
work is growing yeah I and honor you
know one of those company that could
have a new good profit so take some
money of the table and they were built
and successful I think the scene has
really changed so now to take a look at
so all the Silicon Valley visas are
they're pretty much like so you know
Sequoia when they're actually there any
other you name the firm they're all
there and some cardboard front guards
are Eddie's also basically like a Thai
people Langer and doctors are Nexus
India for example you know like we
wanted
Carmel Reiki or you know tygo founded he
started his own inventor so a lot of
people started of Indian origin they
started this cross-border connectivity
to you know help you know Carnarvon
works and get vegetables were kind of
going and the dollars heads continue to
move now what happened that the Indian
you know I talk about the the
the Indian visas have come on the scene
also for example like love it imposes
founders just about everyone of them so
it is mu t what is meant by my reckoning
or ways to mourn that Phi Chris well you
know although all seven eight of them
have their own fund then inputs are
actually his official function has a
billion dollar fund that dealing with
both places we pro oisin Premji he has
his own fund you know investing over
here bonded by son is over here
investing HCL their investment is here
Tata Tata Tata himself in a EG investor
so what happened that these big names in
India who are very renowned they have
gotten that thing and going so so that
that thing is good so that's why it's up
to 25 percent of you know friends
getting Indian VC money yeah cause I
think 10 years ago it would have been
more like five percent or even well yeah
so but still so if I mean it is still
small time we're too young compared to
China compared China yeah so so that's
true now the other thing that you talk
about the regulatory hurdles true they
really are the case so one thing that
happened that the Indian Prime Minister
you know mr. Modi who is very
progressive and very well been oriented
so last year we accurate I assisted with
that we we give them a paper I to if you
really want to promote our own shape and
really help sell succeed so you have to
change some regulations and most of our
Rick medicines really got adapted they
see and ousted so we do is well you know
they just start up India program they
committee like to invest a billion
dollar government fund yes
implementation is slow but nonetheless
the blueprint organized where you know
like you know closing a company in India
where they serve startup come here going
to CERN if you just can't shut a company
how you can kill a company I mean it's
so laws are so take okay so another
there but you know if you were up in the
world opposing promoter and your
business did not succeed and you can't
get condemned you get black mark so you
just cannot start on the company's a lot
of you will you know fill in that
situation they will go and start it up
being the name of their you know why for
so I know
you know or whatever is you know but you
cannot now use your name with it so
these are old British water they adapted
and other country guys are sending in
not just India Europe in the same
problem is take my Japan the same
problem
you started news you fail you know you
get you know you know you did Mark took
a huge mark you guys yeah so so now
there ever is actually just two days ago
Warren Buffett made a comment you know
and he talked when he say hey India is
incredible opportunity but it is a tough
continue to do business with and he
talking about like he won't take Walmart
for example yeah you no Indian
government will not allow Walmart to go
and open their stores that they cannot
have percent for Apple for example Apple
wanted to go now Apple is going now but
it has taken a long time now on the
other hand the gentleman you know
meiosis son you know him now you know
master son and I mean he is amazing he
is committing twenty billion dollars in
India so all the unicorn that he talked
about he master Yoshi so on my sauce
tank japhet huge you know he's out there
you are there with when we when the star
be never launch even the chief guest and
he announced that I'm going to make ten
billion dollars he committed to Prime
Minister Modi and you know then we and
they're invited onto Muslims everywhere
or you know every city you know in India
they all came so this is so there are
people who are saying okay this is
opportunity he think that India is an
action and this is a new Martha's
prediction in the India is an extra and
he calls it a golden African different
sample so so I think you know the the
government is aware of it and they're
mindful of it and Cordia is Elizabeth
could lead us to the Indian corset I
mean very like a ik and the problem is
say again see this is so that's big
different pigeon here in India for
example so when we introduce a bill
delays the u.s. like the or US
government use a bill so you want to
figure out how you're going to pay for
them
so in India they increase the bill will
be passed and you know how do I get you
know who's the paper so I think I don't
know we may be learning that model here
as well but it's so true identity
so the Indian government they passed a
law that bouncing your check is it
physics is a crime it's not a civil
issue it is the termination Wow
so as a result all the people writing
checks and checks are bouncing the core
suggests some of those catechesis now
they don't have judges - you know
preside over a case so the issue is the
court system they don't have Jesus it's
not a sufficient number of people that's
the reason no people to pass it work
whether they didn't invest in that part
and so that's how they call the case
wrote that you have me like the piece I
presenting to the four cases today what
I was reminded just the other day there
all these silly cases like this cheque
bouncing so the each case is equally
important get a judge yeah you know the
judge has got to do them in order you
know exactly exactly so so I think they
have to wade through their canned stuff
but nothing very the problem can we go
back to the investment for a miniature
the fact that foreign and VCS were so
active in India is that generally
regarded as a good thing or does it look
like kind of Imperial control from
outside or one of our speakers a few
weeks ago had a great term she was
talking about bungee mentoring where the
mentors boots and it gives the Bison
disappearance
so are the foreign visas generally
regarded as a positive thing or as a
problem well the data finds anything
because you know I'd you know the money
I mean you know venture capital is money
of invention you know so if you are
inventing idea inventing a new company
and you don't have fun so it's not a bad
thing it's a good thing that money is
good for your monitor now so but we look
at the general investment whether it is
a venture capital or even you know 400
in rural America how capital by
definition is Howard capital flows to
great see the least resistance and it
sees you know it can do more good so
so if you take a look at that so when
people are going to India they say hey
I'm coming in there I thought that
things would be okay but now too much
headache to myself so some people they
get scared they pull away another it is
a bungee you know you're right look at
they went with the whip with the t-6s
finish things are not working out and
when she captain is not because you know
all of you see is not their personal
money they take other people's money so
they also Imperial City it's not you
only infinite wealth that you wanted
okay I can you know you know sit through
it forever
so you have to also get in return but
I'll tell you you know I can tell with
mark Israel at the country I mean look
at you know Israel you know it you know
the desert of land yeah it's you know
easily you know not hard to get into you
go to you know you fly this airline ago
a lot and you get you know the way you
know you get strip-searched all against
that before you can go over there but
some of people still feel loved them so
they knew all that myself indigo so
super many capital companies has gone to
Israel and they've taken it well at many
the opportunity you know the talent and
whatever these are examined created
policies to encourage our worship
locally as a way to attract people our
land okay they have you know situation
in Ireland was you know in a situation
then they rediscover that we have to
attract foreign capital yeah so if you
want to attract foreign capital you had
make it easy again
capital is Howard capital flow to where
it finds the lease which is just we
capital now welcome capital rules Oh in
India suffered actually as a result that
India was you know you know foreign
direct investor in India was not coming
you know it was going illiteracy but
India was not taking advantage that
China amazing China has issues you know
political system it differences is that
but nonetheless
capital has gone to China and people
have gotten a return and you know the
physical body so a lot of the kind of
reputation of India has on the outside
is that it's very closely associated
with social entrepreneurship you know
people like Nobel Prize when you're
Yunus who worked with all the micro
loans and so forth I'm curious how much
of
the sort of new crop of startup
companies are aiming at bottomless
pyramid and how much of it are really
looking at the middle class called the
Indian middle class is also really
growing quickly well III think you know
a first time on floral in India then are
starting you know a social ventures okay
because you know again you know if you
are if you have not succeeded you need
to you know to appreciate if you
generate work for yourself you then you
that gives you level of confidence that
hey you know I kinda made it then you
some generous you know the thing is I
didn't like I always not tell people be
aware the naked men who you know wants
to you know who lend you a shirt off you
know so if it's not there okay I mean I
see some of the young people idealistic
you know you Stanford campus all the
campuses or want to go change the world
you know have add anything and you know
I mean that's not you know if you let me
so money they are we doing these
everything you know I want to talk
social ventures know you need to get
your grounding because whether you're
running a social venture all you running
a for-profit venture you still have to
have that discipline yeah - you know
you've got have a mission in mind and
you got to do it right away otherwise
how would you measure that you succeeded
good point you know so the only
difference between social ventures or
you know for-profit your shareholders
are different ultimately you still have
to give you know reward to the
shareholders people who going to give
you your grants people who give you you
know you know blessed donations or
whatever it is they want to make sure
that their cause you know you are
satisfied therefore then you get the
report on a regular basis that yes you
know you know we are we're doing fine
okay so I think more sample that I see
are barely starting for private ventures
the order they want to become you know
successful they want to create wealth
then they want to feel good in the
community then they want to do you know
chatting whoa so take a look at all the
people like you know again in example
like when she imposes you know where all
the guys that
janabu shouldn't they fit but not no
more than money
go silent poor they didn't go there to
first earn it then you then you learn
after you might be well then you can you
don't know what you want then you do
whatever you want yeah okay so okay so
kind of picking back up on the
government programs so you're talking
about Thai has given this report to the
motif government about startup India and
this has been happening I'm curious what
other kinds of things is the government
putting money to make it easier for
startup companies in terms of like
sponsoring incubators or what kind of
things are going on so yeah that's
happening actually you know every
government you know basically because
they all governments have realized that
the reason we get constant with this
from so many government they come too
tight and they just want to come see
what we do because so the government all
they realize that economic development
is a part of their agenda to a promotion
we cannot make development through
entrepreneurship is part of the agenda
and so here's the time to ease away me
the way the setting of some front aside
go to steadily bigger application
process so you can give some funds and
get some grants they say okay we can
give you a building or you can cool good
you know incubator accelerators but the
to the matter is you know just by giving
your creature comforts like a building
and electricity and you don't baby a
computer and interconnection that's not
already into it you're more like a real
step way I mean that's important but the
missing component is is the mentorship
unless you really have the ecosystem
around it we're successful people can
come and they can may be adaptive in or
adapt an apples and go and get them
actually active advising guidance and
that's where these are interesting cause
even though tires as active as tires you
know India is so big there's just not
enough mentors so they never will be
what
then they won't exactly but it's same
time I also you know say I'm a little
bit more in with my kind of message to a
lot of my colleagues and friends I'm
saying or even it doesn't like even for
you you wanna make a difference whatever
you want to do at least make a
difference for one person you know you
can always help somebody you know so
find one person just imagine how that
could multiply something you don't have
to mentor 500 people or 200 people or
hired people mental high people and
that's okay because you have made a
difference so I was able to you know
sharing your knowledge sharing advice is
a noble thing to do because you can't
take it with you so you might as well
you know and you try to share another
advice you knowledge does not deplete
you know you can share money your
grandpa can deplete you know knowledge
yeah actually you know we learned it was
over one booty but mentoring is the
reason I talk to all the young people
because I just pick up so many ideas
just for young people makes it makes it
easier for me because that I don't go
study so I can talk to somebody has a
tell me about this technology or tell
you about this thing I get a gist of it
and you know I feel good about it so
fish I gotta ask you what makes a good
mentor what makes a good mentor I think
in my view a good mentor is really
someone who really gets into your head
you know in the mentees head simply can
you figure out because a lot of these
mentorship is superficial a lot of
people they don't spend time and I
that's what I spend time with these
people a lot so when people come to me
ask me so I want to be on the move so I
asked them a question like I said great
that's that's I'm so happy that you are
able so tell me why do you want me
enough enough and you've amazed how many
wrong answers there are to this question
and that's right hell you know I I
engaged in a conversation and that's
okay that's okay that's okay but how
about this or that and by just talking
to them listening more so if you can get
over there so that's a
getting the head I like to get more to
the head first of all the developing
blood because again I wanna be a man you
know I'm prover because all you know I
did want this person that made that
sauce to make so much money separating
so successful my question is is good in
a role model if you want to have
somebody to roam arm then try to be a
student at that person what do you know
about that person after the true story
happened many mayors ago this one Apple
cave of inner origin and simply he won't
be after so badly so he country can I
have you can have some time with you
cancer is sure
thank you Dan some time with me and so I
asked him the same question
why do you only happen or and he said oh
because I want to be like Vinod Khosla I
said do you know Vinod he said I know
not really I just heard about him I said
no good note but I don't want to be like
him oh you don't be like that was well
as low as it was wrong with me by my
being me by Bhishma shop and he was just
fraud he said he said oh I said if you
really want to be like him I did you
really don't know much about him
so how can you be like somebody when you
don't know about that person so you have
to really and that's kind of a lot of
people already on with just so for
superficial stuff yeah and even the talk
one even you know the business plan so
it's like by being somebody over the
other question is oh I want to you know
take on this company question what do
you know about the company just because
you read about it as a report you really
know the company's challenging issues
how can you fix the problems so I think
so for any uproar or any lamented that
itself I do I we try to get into get in
the head and and they open up and this
yeah I think I have you know yeah so if
you're the entrepreneur looking for a
mentor and somebody answers your
question with something that makes you
kind of disturbed it's probably a good
thing
absolutely ability because you know a
sale that's fine you know
that's okay go you know because you also
know what give people false guidance and
advice that you're doing you doing that
person more injustice and more
disservice but better not a good thing
okay because our you know my job is to
get the best out of there okay now as
you know even like that start coming you
know the stars are out there even a
typical VC they look at one hundred
company the fund only to two percent but
we need to be sealed for any investor
because this woman has other people I
don't know who which two people really
have the best ideas or who really have
it so I have to talk to everybody so
that's the other thing that also is very
important for for VC because and that's
what this hard time talking everybody
mm-hmm and just because they talk to you
and they didn't own you that's not a bad
thing just because you talk to them you
know and using it funded that's not a
bad thing for you either so for you to
raise capital you really have to go and
talk to lack people so as the amount of
investment money in India has
drastically increased the entrepreneurs
of course are learning how to pitch
better so they're aiming bigger but are
you concerned yet that maybe it's going
to get a little bit too easy and so the
quality of plans or the quality of
execution may go down well these always
I tell you this is police
self-correcting system what happened in
widget when the abundance of capital and
then critical damage serving is hard so
of course you know I mean this is make
you know a lot of mistakes
so they'll bet on something and they
know there's notice so there's a lot of
dollars changing you know a few good
ideas yeah and also same time and I
preneur like oh gosh knows is you know
now everybody has I see every day the
whole gig economy oh you know I move up
for this over for that I mean this is I
don't know when Google became you know I
mean every day I will see a company
it's another search in the company oh I
think I have better than you know Google
you know
so so that doesn't thing also happens
but the thing is that just because a lot
of cap is available
people just don't become smart all of a
sudden just because of our money so I
tell people you know because we're
biological creatures we don't evolve you
know money can you uh you know of like
add a lot of subject capital but the
thing is but it's a human brain we don't
evolve so I tell people no you have to
be very focused into what it whatever
that you want to do and it's not it is
not about you have to learn to pitch
better that that's a wrong thing to do
it is the strength of your business plan
that matters
it is what it is that you want to you
know what probably want is solve so I I
give you know every Emperor you know
when they come to is let me show you my
powerpoint I simply turn it computer off
I want you to tell me the story and even
I guide them I said I want you I want to
hear your story in this order and that
really works for me and it actually
works in the better but that's a very
good mentoring the whole they're always
very simple you have to focus if we find
for me what caching problem you want
address that exists in much a pressing
problem if they'd pressing need in the
society people will spend money on it
people want to get that one address so
after you identify the pressing need
tell me how is that needs being
satisfied today that's more competition
business cool Java miracle competition
if there's a pressing problem believe me
maybe you don't know that
oh why not it nobody else is doing it
well my friend you just have not been
outside you know just go out look around
okay if the pressing needs some people
tell you addressing you just don't know
it so identify this half a dozen or so
people who tend solve problem and then
you should know it very well okay
they're saying that the weaknesses and
define your point based upon that and
why your approach to address the problem
is far superior and I'm not I'm a
technologist define your approach to
address a problem in a far superior way
because we don't have a possibility
approach people don't switch it only
feel product
service you know we computed by all I
don't like my car I don't like my
neighborhood I don't but you know we
just don't go by another car we don't go
to houses you know so just because
somebody complains about little things
that's not to call the person you okay
so define your approach and how wide is
personal then the fourth element to your
plan is two stories
tell me what does it take to build a
business and start with you who are you
what are you really good at
honest to goodness because you cannot
make it up if you imagine something
believe me people figure out the generic
or something so you might as well tell
them truth so I'm this I'm a great
architect I've not done a you know
product you know I can't even build a
product but I'm really a good designer
for example but I'm not a good that's
okay I have no clue about how to sell it
I have no clue how to market I don't
know how to read capital that's okay be
yourself so start off with you be
brutally honest and say I need help here
here here because any investor or mentor
want to look at your idea they are
constantly mean but how can I have this
person but unless they hear from you
you know what help you need is very hard
for them to guess so you be honest and
the last thing is what did it bring in
in terms of revenue and profits because
you have no profit bodies you have no
right to be in business because you
generally cannot generate profit you can
obtain invoice you can service your
customers and your business of sale so
profit is not a bad thing this is how
businesses succeed this have been
associate world for themselves and for
the community that's how you build
amazing so those are the five points are
attentive 5 points 10 minutes maybe 15
worth of the most and also let them know
that listen nobody at planet perfect and
the waste project so if you might your
video because the world is full of their
people and I think usually go with that
you'll be amazed how you feel so
liberated because the other person who
listen to story you know sound like you
same hardware you know that
here's mouth you know you know eat food
you know breathe their same softer so
while you sew up you know Chintan lovers
shouldn't get concern because a person
we want to listen to you with a Dementor
or the investor don't help you so you
all be remembered II really want to help
you so you should be very you should
feel good about it and you know and
don't think don't get uptight don't be
too anxious should've anxieties and and
good to tell you you know I like your
idea but it's not for me because I
already have five companies in the same
space that you have so I don't want this
example you know like that so yeah so
that's really good advice I'm seeing a
lot of startup companies here that want
to expand globally earlier than usual
that want to really start say doing
their development in some place like
India or they want to really get into
the rapidly emerging markets that are
happening in Southeast Asia or India
what kind of advice would you give to a
Silicon Valley startup that's
considering that kind of expansion
should they how do you compare India to
other places and also what should they
know before they go into India so so
here's what I out - I mean it's okay for
a small start-up to think like a micro
multinational company I mean you could
be a 50% company and you could be a CRO
multinational but I'll have only one
caution
don't try to expand into multiple
markets same time it's okay to have your
distributors you can have your priority
whether in one place support another
place and production another location
just keep that in mind but don't go into
other market you have to know one market
so if you are a silly merry startup you
know less American something you have to
know American market first you have to
succeed in your own backyard if you have
not succeed your own backyard with your
business yeah these are is no tie to
reduce you know big big big shoulder
challenge the reason people are going to
India I mean
every other said Emily started today you
know Heather operation you know design
you know all engineering operation
somewhere else every other techniques I
mean it just move just unreal sending
14500 same way so so you're doing
because you go to Canada going to
Vancouver or Toronto or are you going to
you know you know India because you
can't have talent there are no so you
need to find you know so you might wanna
take a business with a talented since
you can bring Italian over here in a
hurry so it's okay to do that part so
you can do the support function you know
maybe some some in your name function
you know but don't try to go and tap
into market because what do you know
what the culture the new one said again
you don't know those customers you don't
know the first thing is they have just
because your address in the US does not
mean that other geography have the same
problem yeah same needs okay so I would
say don't go look for new markets in
other countries but do go look for
talent and good you know I am in
spending a twenty four by seven
situation delays because the speed is
all very speedy they now compare
advantage for business because a lot of
you know ideas that you have is very
easy to not replicate even though you
may have some technology protection you
know barrier for a while but it's the
one that word gets out other people will
not go around
yeah they can't they can do that yeah
yeah okay let's open before the
questions we party with questions in the
audience no one over there I think for
taking your time to move says Bishop I
had a question about look what are your
thoughts on the how the market looks for
non tech startups in India right now or
Mumbai in particular so when you say non
tech startup
what a moment construction yeah so well
construction is a big market in India
because of India you know is a the
country you know you know actually the
Indian Prime Minister has made a amazing
statement he wants to have housing for
everybody
buy some here okay so every no
politician make all the declarations you
know but but it so all it means is that
they want to kind of ease the lending
for the people because a lot of people
they can borrow money or they want to
make sure that they can support the
economy by encouraging you know more
dealers to come on the scene and start
building you know was it low income
outside as well as you know you know
other type houses so I think that
opportunity pretty right but again the
if you want to go and type to do
construction in India now that that's
what you have to really you gotta find
local person to work with you because
otherwise the you know chance of you
succeeding in a construction business
local marketing it tough yeah that tends
to be a highly regulated market and it
also tends to require diverse resources
so it's never of a big company play the
F word the big go ahead did I have
anyone in the kind of construction field
in Mumbai oh yes love it we just had a
gentleman from India came we just had
our conference he's one of the big
builders and he has built you know a lot
of units in India from based in Pune and
he decided to expand to Australia and he
actually expanding his operation here
here he's building senior housing in
Hayward because he had figured out the
way and he's building for basically
Indian Indian community they say well
you know I can build houses to death
needs because it's just like you know
every house has you know you know
Western marriages and the different
design Indians of a different design
most people are religious so you gotta
be shine in the house you gotta have in
good the outside your face like the
Chinese you know you got to do the
proper you just can't face any which
direction because that's not a bad
almond you know so you got make sure
that so so so this builder and he came I
just fond sir
he orders a check because I want to come
and net were the people and he was able
to persuade other people so we know that
we know the people we got big better so
whatever example so one of the you know
the data is a big big company so one of
the biggest shares in that company that
I'd is a builder so as well as a real
conglomerate with lots of others that
say yeah ok good so as you mentioned
that we don't really have a very
positive attitude towards say dried
light Rasulullah to go elect our social
ventures in countries like India and
stuff like that so I mean I was just
wondering that if you think there's a
fundamental difference between like your
and India then it in India people
generally once a like for profits
because they want to make money and if
you have a Stanford student doing a
start-up it's probably likely that it's
going to be like I'm gonna solve all the
problems the body we're not going to
make start curly but you shouldn't ride
our something about what the given the
fundamental difference in asking the
people on what do you think is the root
cause of this difference between well
you know at a higher level okay you
captures the India was a US for example
so you se the most philanthropic country
on the face of the earth
you know that this is huge I mean we are
like more than three hundred and fifty
billion dollars Americans give away you
know a lot of money you go to the school
go to churches go to there to other you
know so well in the other on the other
hand it's like 150 you know it's like
only three billion dollars so you know
Indian you know people in India they
were again they built the temples they
do work in other cancer but the social
ventures as we know in the u.s. is not
there I mean the country that comes next
to us is UK for example so these social
ventures actually you know like it or
not but it is the very much a Western
except we really start in the West and
of course it's a literally on to the to
the churches because you know before we
had for security in this country the one
who said such thing is social security
people live in the community and people
knew that sub person is hard on the lock
and then your neighbors who take care of
them and they'll take care of family all
kinds of but then as a country grew and
then you know family started moving
apart and you know elderly people you
know did live with the children anymore
so we created this whole you know social
security concept you know you know
mandated pension kind of cancer so if
you can live off okay like that so so
the people who are doing I think what is
happening that the Indian youth
I'm very impressive the Indian youth
actually of all India is the two-thirds
population are very young anyway so it's
a massive number youth so these people
now listening I want my credit to be
there
I want my current bill you know so I see
a lot of you know inspired youth they
want to make a difference in India for
example in the big wave but now they
don't that means because to want to even
larger social ventures they need a funds
over here like a particular years now
many venture firms have you know sprung
up here you know they object they call
that the impact in their stream crack
yeah you know a good time I know where
I'll either Enterprise it's called
double double bottom line you know
ventures you know the dbl ventures okay
we just added one track was developed to
social impact at ICON and I'd like a
money talk why here tribunal fun and
that's what he wants to do he said I
want to you know generate profit but
since I am also looking for the highly
scalable so anything that do the water
sanitation energy you know the thing
that message in India for Japanese so
that whether it's a health related or
energy related those kind of ventures
are getting funded and a lot of people
saying I want to do something you know
in the slums I want to something I do
any of you from you in here they want
Africa a good friend of mine they want
to do things in Aero be the something
ROV but they want to
business manner because otherwise a
whatever if you don't do that Reggie
charity you just give till handout and
before you know they're consumed it and
you have met initially you have not
leverage that that that investment so if
you don't mind me commenting on this yes
that's like that how the process of
coming up with an idea for being an
entrepreneur usually involves solving a
problem yes I guess it and so the young
people are very aware of that kind of
things are needed in India right the
people there have like young people
everywhere they see what's around them
they find something unpleasant or
inefficient and they see an opportunity
I think that probably the nature of the
idea itself and look down the road five
or ten years what's going to happen if
you go to for-profit route versus the
nonprofit route the good thing about a
for-profit route is there's an exit and
you can build it up to something big and
it becomes a public company or somebody
else buys it out but there's kind of an
ending if you create a non-profit there
really is no exit and that's hard you
must create a sustainable business model
otherwise you can't keep going all
you're doing is giving yourself to
provide a service but unless you find
other people like ira aaron price who is
doing you know impact investing it's
really hard ten years later to find
other people who can pick this up and
keep it going instead of you and that's
really kind of the basic point of a
negative so you kind of need to do what
is the right thing for that idea if the
idea is something that really should
stay nonprofit because it's there's an
aspect to it it just isn't business then
do it do it that way and play in your
life accordingly but otherwise do it as
a profit as a for-profit because it's
better for the idea
if they make you mentioned that the
government change that you have Modi
Lake starting the data video setup so
you take like there's a sort of
different in how can you save India L
towards nonprofits and profits and you
can pick like God like you given some
difference in the ease of setting up one
or the other kind of organization well
I'll give you an example that I'm
personally involved with data in India
because you know the all the public
schools you know that poor kids go to
school they go hungry and so Indian
Supreme Court remanded if that kids are
really good midday meal fight that we
can evolve example so now you know put
the tax map there's money you know I had
to go and fund these meals and of course
the waste reduction so you know money is
you know allocated but you won't go so
or listen castor didn't Bangalore is
called a chap at Radha's the name of the
organization and so all they did was
they said okay we're going to argument
this thing and you are done
you know purely through donor supported
organization but the entire process is
run amazing any business if successful
business last year except at reserve one
point six million means for example and
these means are like fifteen cents we
can feed it child meals and these are
healthy nutritious the this woman reader
dinner the nutrition department in
Chicago I think she came with a menu and
only two kinds of meals shouting and
Kitty one guy no teammates case what
will eat one type now they have kitchens
all over and even they offer the process
that you can like make like you know the
Indian bread is called chapati roll even
two hundred thousand rotis you know like
you know you cook this a heavy machine
the custom design of you know operation
the way you cook rice the way you cook
is just amazing and during the the white
trucks come on
so our there in India in 2009 December
Jaipur was my door whether we have a
tiny trade we want to visit the kitchen
we just loved the idea so we started a
chip
over here so they responded without one
for type members from Boston
you know guys Excel opera very generous
so he the chair of that and we started
raising money and now they went to the
Indian companies corporations and they
employ a payroll deduction plan they set
up people give to payroll deductions and
but do it isn't it absolute business no
matter fact they got did the best
business award by the chair accountants
Association of India they got Microsoft
getting the best education award from
here so because the way they run it is
unreal so it's a social venture in a way
but it's all done and a lot of
volunteers you know and then they employ
the women all the mothers and also
getting employment so they feel good
about themselves and case at least
having just won a race they even you
know just I think one good meal a day
and you know even the innovation came
because then they debated the mean so
pretty so kids can do well I know I'm
going to get the same thing on Monday
Tuesday Wednesday so they will don't eat
so they kind of added a little dessert
and they didn't tell me they didn't get
or get the dessert for example so the
kids who are don't just a meet a meal
and working school because they didn't
know what they deserve will be served
for okay so it's like you know lot of
ambition the connector and and this is
one of the amazing example and a lot
other examples also of that that people
are starting in a small way in a big way
but you had to be driven to that purpose
you have to identify the pressing needs
that exist and you got to be committed
to it and again and convince your donors
are the reason that I am indeed
satisfying the needs in a better way
okay and you are making a difference so
you have to have more accounting more
reporting that you have to just make
your business you got to give it a
little you know a report there our last
last year we thought we featured the
Bohemian hemp company in this series oh
yeah which is a very interesting company
that feeds part of its profits back to
the farmers in India yeah right it helps
them grow
hemp seeds yep and for various uses that
are all legal and it really is an
interesting company so but it's a
business say it isn't so
one more Scott or okay yeah Scott
fascinating I I noticed you go you
went to the indignant to the technology
in the City of Light Barnaba yes and I'm
curious to what degree that is tie
networking with IITs in India maybe even
along the for-profit you know oriented
entrepreneurial tie with maybe
conceptually the nonprofit IITs and I
asked us in developing an MIT
OpenCourseWare centric online university
that seeks to create major universities
in all 22 official languages in India
well thank you yeah so well I did a lot
of the type members reading out of all
it also IIT folks if you take a little
the type ends over here the the eighth
the eighth person that we have I think
other than three anyways deities alum
for example so from IIT Kharagpur IIT
you know from Bombay like I was you know
barnsey so there's a lot of Finity with
IIT and I and the IIT has started in
Croatian centers for example iit bombay
IG Madras is innovations in a very
successful one IT Warren C has started
that and our people can't pull the puter
already helping them out as a result of
that a lot of people whenever they go
they make a visit and they go teach a
class they go you know an older session
and they talk about a particular topic
so that that's really happening in a big
way and I think and so they're giving
back in a big way yeah so okay behind go
ahead I just wanted to ask for the more
successful startups that you've seen in
India do you find that they're started
by first time or new entrepreneurs or
people who are in industry and then let
the corporate world to start the these
startups
actually what we're seeing right now is
just like over here you know a
professional is working in a company
large company whether it's HP or cysts
or Intel or Google or Facebook now you
know whatever and they get an idea that
I want to start a company in here the
same way these people are working in a
job or in a career and this l want to
start a company I don't see many
corporate executives out of India
wearing them you know in a corporate
work for so 15 20 years and saying I
want to tell a company that you need
does not happen doesn't have any here
either it's very hard if you have you
know corporate execs for 15 20 years and
you want to go start a company it's
usually not the case so it's the younger
people who are you know employed by
major corporations now of late what is
happening is that we see the drop out at
IIT you know rate had increased because
a lot of these young people say well I'm
only bright and we're smart and why
should I finish my you know IIT you know
for here why don't I start a company so
that's happening so people from there
they're you know you know dropping out
and selling company because they're
capping the the the American you know
success story yeah so this where do you
see this going this is last question for
the day what do you see about the
prospects for India in the future do you
think that it's going to be able to keep
up in a new world in which China is more
competitive and bigger or what's going
to happen well I definitely you know the
bet that we made on India you know many
many years ago I think it is happening
and now the the the the whole attitude
of Indian you know public is very good
they want beyond prover they want to
generate wealth and the Indian people
are always very inviting you know I mean
I tell you because India has two main
rules regulations but think figure out a
way to still so India is a country very
enterprising there is not about that
yeah and I think with now the the
capital being available
you know the robot ring available the
policy changing you can see this whole
unleashing of the new kind of company
coming out it is good to get with the
young people
this is young people India I have a lot
of faith in them young clean they're
going to make a few difference that's a
great comment in the section on thank
you so much for a great heart so thank
you very / absolutely yeah thank you
[Applause]